the new shows is me Savannah and the
rest of the people in my family and my
dad's one of the smartest human beings
that I've ever met he was like run it
through the roof Chase Chrisley getting
reality TV tips from an expert his dad
Todd Chrisley listen no one's life is
laughter all the time we wish it were
but you know we have a lot of real
moments I mean it's reality television
of course the advice comes while his dad
and mom Julie are behind bars
it was tough I mean it's still tough and
after Todd first teased the project back
in December the documentary that's being
that we're working on right now is going
to be very telling and we hope that our
fans will Embrace that what do you know
about this documentary and the message
that the
definitely wants to now show the world I
can just tell you there is there is a
story there about what they've been
through the past year or two that hasn't
been told it would be how we are all
dealing with things and that's his
sister Savannah with an update last
month power navigating it together as a
family the new shows is me Savannah and
the rest of the people in my family now
the
drops new details on the Chase and
birdies podcast
you have to get a production deal done
first and then they'll take it out and
sell it my dad's one of the smartest
human beings that I've ever met so when
I could
when I do get to see him and talk to him
yeah I tell him about everything get his
his input
and he loves to see us win he was like
run it through the roof we have a fan
base now that that we want to make them
proud but Chase warns fans don't expect
the happy-go-lucky Vibes of Chrisley
Knows Best
we're going to Florida it's pastel
season currently in its 10th season and
with Todd and Julie in prison likely to
be the show's final episodes
our new show that we've got coming out
is
it's definitely going to be different
it's going to be real Raw
The Good the Bad and the Ugly so yeah
the Chrisley's lives look a little
different compared to their TV debut in
2014. we signed up for a show that has
entertained millions and millions and
millions of people but what we didn't
sign up for is to be lied on following
their convictions for bank fraud and tax
evasion Todd and Julie serving a
combined 19-year prison sentence
I've never seen two people my parents be
so steadfast in their faith and in the
end the truth will prevail may get
harder before it gets easier but we have
faith as Chase tells it the new series
coincides with the family's other big
project we're still fighting yeah we've
already our appeals already been filed I
think they're optimistic but let me be
clear I think that optimism is well
placed this trial was riddled with heirs
and we expect the appeals court to see
that I don't think that God will
put you through a storm that he won't
bring you out of yeah God didn't bring
us this far to drop us off
[Music]